okay let's try going to our next caller
from the 484 area any time we go to four
eight four things can get a little dicey
who's calling from for eight for today
it's me David George from Downingtown I
knew it I knew it Jarrod I knew it was
you what's going on nothing much
completed I predicted Trump was going to
tweet something racist today I said
tomorrow okay let's see he said the
Native American comment when he was with
the Navajo Indians yeah and then the
next day I said okay he's definitely
gonna tweet something racist today and
it's like oh it's like III becoming I've
become almost like I can I can read
Trump's mind at this point it seems like
every time he needs a distraction it's
time to tweet something out and I wonder
just like how much his tweets are
actually him doing it like you know it's
like maybe it's his inner racism and Fox
News you know grandpa mindset and how
much of it is just like a distraction
it's a good question I don't have an
answer but I have a question for you
Jared which is you you said you could
almost read Trump's mind do you believe
in the concept of mind-reading and sort
of psychic powers mm-hmm no not per se I
I can I can follow patterns like I can I
can somewhat like with my animals like
sometimes like if I if we haven't this
little thing going on where we can kind
of like understand each other and you
and your end it's my cat
yes huh so is it like real like an ASIS
or is it like telepathic contact with
your cat no it's not telling telekinesis
it's more just like just we understand
what's going on you know what I'm saying
we kind of we kind of know what what's
going on but in what sense in terms of
science or a policy I don't like safe
yeah not nothing to do with politics
okay
don't put my my my meatball for my dog
my dog is just gonna start growling and
going where's the meatball at I want my
meatball I'm like okay all right there
you go
and the cat it's just got this little
thing going on where if you feed him
once and if you don't it you can feed
them once but then he'll go to somebody
else and just like start plugging them
only except me of course is this making
any sense to you Pat this is one of a
kind I've never heard of anything like
this or yeah well seem to want food
well Jarrod you've said it all and
appreciate the call good to hear from
you
any cap all right Thank You Jarrod from
Downingtown in a little while since uh
since we heard from